hey guys it is Tuesday my name is Jess
I'm Dan and this is the last time you'll
be seeing us this week because we're
heading off to pax Australia
that's right game so let's go to theater
again we've got panels I'll be there
taking photos of all of you in your
cosplay and what are some of the cool
panels they can come see at a theater
Jess also many panels more than I could
possibly name in this improvised intro
but if you want to find out you can find
out on our respective Twitter accounts
for now there are kids news
first up the latest Nintendo switch
system update that had a gameplay
recording just keeps getting better
that's right you can now play games with
you GameCube controller could that mean
update 4.0 allows anyone with a GameCube
controller and the USB adapter that's
sold with super smash brothers for Wii U
to plug in and play there's a few
downsides though the GameCube controller
doesn't feature a Z L button and there's
no home button so getting back to the
system menu it's a bit tricky now I know
what you're all thinking and I'm
thinking it too please let this be
Nintendo laying the groundwork to smash
on switch if you haven't grabbed the
latest update for your console handheld
hybrid there's also the aforementioned
gameplay recording a fresh coat of paint
to the news feed and the ability to
transfer saves and users between systems
what are you doing I'm physically hiding
why because player unknowns
battlegrounds the digital hide-and-seek
game is getting a physical release on
Xbox one at e3 this year Microsoft
revealed that everyone's favorite
digital hide-and-seek experience player
unknowns battlegrounds that would be
coming to Xbox one is a console launch
exclusive we still don't have a concrete
release date for the game which is still
in early access on Steam the game's
twitter accounts has now revealed you'll
be able to get your hands on a physical
version of the Xbox one edition if
you're so inclined will it come with a
manual perhaps a map of the island do
you remember the Simpsons songs in the
key of Springfield and the disc was a
donut
I want that level of detail on this
edition it would be it'll be a skillet
it was 100% musical in it there's no
word yet if or when pubget will make it
to ps4 but we have heard that Microsoft
has been working on increasing the
game's exclusivity deal on Xbox I'll be
sure to keep you up to date with
everything Xbox pubget and iron cookware
so keep tuning in we finally have a
definitive answer as to whether or not
single player DLC is going to be
arriving for Grand Theft Auto 5 and it's
not what we were hoping for during an
interview with Game Informer Rockstar
Director MRAM Sawa explained that it
wasn't really a conscious decision not
to release single player DLC for GTA 5
it just sort of happened he went on to
say quote the storytelling and a sense
of immersion in a world multiplayer
games don't rival single-player games
with GTA 5 the single-player game was
absolutely massive and very very
complete there was also apparently the
problem of resources and the company's
focus on their next big release Red Dead
Redemption 2 if you can remember back to
December of 2013 Rockstar teased but
never fully committed to releasing
substantial additions to GTA 5 that
would continue the stories of the three
main characters it was never explicitly
stated what form these would take and it
seems like things just got in the way
don't fret it doesn't sound like
Rockstar are moving away from
single-player games as the last that we
still love single-player from world
games more than anything I don't think
you could make a game like GTA 5 if you
did not like single-player games and
trying to expand their possibilities but
it's know what you think about this one
in that comment box below that's it
we're off to Melbourne to go to pax
Australia and if you can't make it to
Melbourne you can watch all of our
panels streamed right here on
gamespot.com so make sure you tune in to
see us to talk about mean comments we've
received a dummy's guide to heed sports
and 30-hour games in three minutes
somehow explaining the entire Final
Fantasy saga in three minutes yeah I'm
really excited for that first one yeah
you guys should be excited for that
first one if you want any of the details
as I said do check out Twitter accounts
unfortunately that does mean there will
be no GS news episode tomorrow but the
other two days per all the rest of the
week will be covered by the u.s. so
you'll be able to get your news fixed so
you guys know I'm seeing Ellen Dan what
you're doing I'm hiding you're hiding is
that because that's the way to win the
biggest game in the world right now
player unknowns battle grams well
another thing there is
[Music]